por qué
[Música]
el congreso de eeuu ratificó la victoria
del presidente de electoral demócrata
joe biden y su vicepresidenta kamala
harris en las elecciones de noviembre
tras una jornada sin precedentes que
terminó a las 4 de la mañana luego de un
asalto al capitolio por parte de
seguidores del presidente saliente de
donald trump quien en la madrugada de
este jueves reconoció que su mandato ha
terminado y prometió una transición en
orden tenemos reportes desde washington
la noche de caos en eeuu tras la toma
del congreso por parte de los seguidores
del presidente de trump culminó con
cuatro personas fallecidas y una cadena
de dimisiones entre altos cargos de la
casa blanca entretanto legisladores
estadounidenses prometieron investigar
la forma en la que la policía del
capitolio manejó el violento asalto
cuestionando así si falta preparación y
permitió esta falta de preparación de la
turba ocupase y causas de los destrozos
los demócratas ganaron los dos escaños
en georgia y lograron el control del
senado con las victorias confirmadas de
los senadores raphael warnock y jon as
of el partido demócrata tiene en sus
manos el poder en ambas cámaras un poder
que permitirá al presidente electo joe
biden tener un apoyo legislativo para
sus planes de gobierno en la casa blanca
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
entradas 24 sierra blanca un gusto
saludarlos comenzamos en eeuu donde el
congreso finalmente ratificó a joe biden
y kamala harris como presidente y
vicepresidenta de electos superando la
barrera de los 270 votos electorales
quedan las llaves de la casa blanca el
vicepresidente estadounidense mike pence
que presidía la sesión certificó
solemnemente el resultado electoral
varios de los 12 senadores republicanos
que habían anunciado que intentarían
cambiar el resultado de la votación
final en algunos estados
resistieron de hacerlo y ambas cámaras
por una aplastante mayoría ratificaron
la decisión de los colegios electorales
pence puso fin a una sesión que comenzó
a primera hora de la tarde de ayer que
fue interrumpida por el violento asalto
al capitolio por parte de los seguidores
del presidente de donald trump que duró
casi cuatro horas y se saldó con cuatro
muertos 14 policías heridos y al menos
52 personas fueron detenidas
los votos para presidentes son los
siguientes bailen 306 from 232
tenemos el anuncio del estado del voto
por parte del presidente del senado se
considerará una declaración suficiente
de las personas elegidas presidente y
vicepresidente de eeuu cada uno por el
período que comienza el día 20 de enero
de 2021 guárico aragua
y por su parte el presidente saliente de
donald trump aceptó este jueves que su
presidencia será de un solo mandato y
prometió una transición ordenada después
de que el congreso ratificara la
victoria electoral del mandatario electo
joe biden e la vicepresidenta cámara
carles el anuncio lo hizo a través de la
cuenta de twitter de uno de sus
principales asesores yanes k vino luego
de que esta red social le borrara un
trino en el que parecía a condonar lo
ocurrido y bloqueará su cuenta por 12
horas aunque estoy totalmente en
desacuerdo con el resultado de las
elecciones y los hechos me respaldan
habrá una transición ordenada el 20 de
enero siempre he dicho que continuaremos
nuestra lucha para asegurarnos que sólo
se contarán los votos legales si bien
esto representa el final del mejor
primer mandato en la historia
presidencial es solo el comienzo de
nuestra lucha para hacer que eeuu vuelva
a ser grande
vamos hasta washington dice con nuestro
corresponsal cristóbal vázquez cristóbal
muy buen día como podemos resumir lo
ocurrido ayer en washington una jornada
sin precedentes que sin duda pasará a la
historia del país
empezó con la convocatoria de bl
presidente saliente de la marcha safe
américa a las afueras de la casa blanca
donde dio un discurso en ese discurso
dijo que simplemente no se iba a dejar
robar la elección y pues invitó a los
manifestantes a sus simpatizantes a que
caminaran hacia el capitolio
los simpatizantes llegaron al capitolio
a eso del mediodía pasado el mediodía a
la una de la tarde cuando ya estaba
empezando pues esta sesión protocolaria
para contar y certificar la elección
presidencial sin embargo en esa
certificación que normalmente se demora
30 minutos pues uno presiones o
presiones de senadores republicanos que
pues no reconocieron los votos de los
delegados electorales y esto llevó a que
las dos cámaras se separaran para
debatir y votar estas opresiones fue
precisamente cuando las dos cámaras
estaban divididas cuando los
manifestantes simpatizantes de donald
trump se toman el
capitolio y solo fue entonces a las
cinco y media de la tarde hora de
washington que las autoridades las más
de 1100 cuerpos de la guardia nacional y
los cientos de cuerpos de la policía del
capitolio logran retomar el control
desde el capitolio para que entonces a
las 8 de la noche de ayer volviera a
restablecerse la sesión para certificar
a joe biden como presidente la
certificación entonces se dio pasadas ya
las tres y media de la mañana de hoy
cuando
mike pence en calidad de presidente del
senado que certifica ayo bailén contando
los votos los 306 votos que sacó en la
pasada elección del 3 de noviembre y
pues declarando indirectamente
presidente de eeuu
cristóbal hablemos ahora de la actuación
de la policía y los cuerpos de seguridad
como un grupo de personas puedo tomar el
congreso de esa manera sin un
impedimento mayor de la policía y como
las imágenes de ayer también contrastan
con el amplio
de las fuerzas de seguridad que hemos
visto cuando hay protestas del
movimiento black light mar
claro está hay muchas preguntas por
ejemplo dónde estaban los helicópteros
porque no se usaron gases lacrimógenos
las balas de goma porque tampoco se
usaron los explosivos por ejemplo todas
estas herramientas de intimidación que
tanto usó la fuerza pública en las
protestas pacíficas que se dieron en
frente de la casa blanca a principios de
año donde estuvimos cubriendo las allá y
donde fuimos víctimas precisamente de
esos gases lacrimógenos que pues lanzó
la policía donde están por ejemplo los
caballos protegiendo el círculo del
capitolio donde están los anillos de
seguridad que se usaron y el despliegue
tan amplio que hubo de la fuerza pública
para esta protesta que todo el mundo
sabía iba a tornarse violenta
precisamente porque se hacía el 6 de
enero día de la certificación desde el
presidente yo bailén en el congreso
muchas preguntas y muchos interrogantes
se dejan porque por ejemplo la policía
del capitolio cuando vio que los
manifestantes estaban acercándose a la
del capitolio lo publicó y sharon fue el
gas pimienta y pues palos para
contrarrestar al final fue un agente el
que termina disparando una persona y la
termina matando pero pues quedan muchas
preguntas y esto será obviamente un tema
que se abordará en el futuro
cristóbal gracias por la información que
tengo usted muy buen día por supuesto
muy pendientes de lo que ocurra también
el día de hoy en eeuu como lo venimos
diciendo washington dice vivió este
miércoles un episodio hasta ayer
impensable en la principal democracia
del mundo después de un discurso
incendiario del presidente de donald
trump durante una manifestación
convocada por él una multitud de sus
partidarios irrumpieron el congreso
cuando los congresistas se disponían a
ratificar los resultados las elecciones
de noviembre una mujer murió como
consecuencia de un disparo y otras tres
personas fallecieron por emergencias
médicas
hemos recuento que nos presenta juan
pupiales
eran dos procesiones una rumbo a las
afueras de la casa blanca otra la de los
congresistas que se reunían para
certificar la victoria de joe biden en
las elecciones
el telón lo abrió el presidente del
trump el mandatario había pedido a
grandes multitudes que se congregarán
este miércoles para su discurso una rara
intervención en los últimos de su
mandato pero con un mensaje repetido
nunca concederemos eso no va a pasar uno
no concede cuando hay robo involucrado
un discurso incendiario que terminó
siendo la antesala de la que iba a ser
la ratificación de los votos del colegio
electoral en el congreso y que tendría
un desenlace nunca visto
es un trámite que en esta ocasión se
veía interrumpido en un principio por el
anuncio de varios congresistas
republicanos para pedir una auditoría en
algunos estados
estos legisladores se amparaban en las
denuncias sin pruebas de un supuesto
fraude electoral en los comicios de
noviembre las miradas sobre el
vicepresidente mike pence antes en su
discurso del presidente de trump había
afirmado de manera errónea que pence
tenía la capacidad para no aceptar los
votos electorales algo que el propio
vicepresidente desmintió en un
comunicado afuera la multitud seguía con
la hoja de ruta de la protesta y se
dirigía al congreso empezó el caos la
manifestación llegó a las escaleras del
capitolio adentro se suspendía la
votación los legisladores se ponían bajo
resguardo algunos dentro de sus propios
despachos
los seguidores de trump ya estaban por
el salón de las estatuas y luego dentro
del mismo senado llegó entonces la
intervención del presidente electo joe
biden y una petición para donald trump
alcohol
le pido al presidente de donald trump
que salga en televisión nacional ahora
para que cumpla con su juramento y
defienda la constitución y pida que se
acabe este asedio si yo hablo pero por
twitter
fuimos una elección que fue robada fue
una elección ganada por gran distancia y
todo el mundo lo sabe especialmente en
otro labio pero tienen que ir a casa
ahora tenemos que lograr la paz
peace
el epicentro de la democracia se
convirtió en un escenario de choques y
con la muerte de una mujer consecuencia
de un disparo dentro del capitolio se
desplegó la guardia nacional la policía
metropolitana y hasta el servicio
secreto caía la noche y el congreso
quedaba despejado pero la sombra de ese
día nunca se borrará de la historia
y es que estos inéditos hechos de
violencia en el capitolio de eeuu
acapararon la atención global los
principales líderes del mundo incluyendo
algunos cercanos a donald trump
condenaron las acciones
condena asombro e indignación en el
mundo líderes globales rechazaron en
inédito asalto en el capitolio de eeuu
desde francia emmanuel macrón envió su
apoyo a los estadounidenses
washington es no tener y lo que pasó en
washington destino es estados unidos
definitivamente creemos en la fortaleza
de nuestras democracias y creemos en la
fortaleza de la democracia
estadounidense
en alemania angela merkel responsabilizó
a donald trump por crear una atmósfera
que posibilitó los incidentes y expresó
su repudio a todos vimos las
inquietantes imágenes del asalto al
congreso de eeuu
esas imágenes me enojaron y también me
entristeció
que mostró una postura compartida con
los mandatarios europeos
el rechazo llegó incluso de aliados
políticos de trump como boris johnson
que reprobó las imágenes vergonzosas o
benjamín netanyahu desde israel
el alboroto en el capitolio fue un acto
vergonzoso y debe ser condenado
enérgicamente no tengo ninguna duda de
que la democracia estadounidense
prevalecerá siempre lo ha hecho proceso
roberts
rusia o turquía también se sumaron al
repudio y rivales políticos como china
irán o venezuela una condena que no fue
ajena américa latina' con mensajes de
gobernantes como sebastián piñera en
chile alberto fernández en argentina
iván duque en colombia o lenin moreno en
ecuador
en eeuu los demócratas han recuperado el
control del senado después de ganar los
dos asientos en disputa en georgia
el pastor raphael warnock y yo nos soft
derrotaron a sus rivales republicanos
por primera vez en 20 años
un cambio electoral sorprendente en
georgia ya que los dos candidatos
demócratas ganaron sus carreras por el
senado aseguran una mayoría en la cámara
alta para su partido y mejoran
drásticamente el destino de la agenda
del presidente electo joe biden en una
reñida contienda el reconocido
periodista de investigación john o soft
de 33 años superó al republicano david
perdió convirtiéndose en el senador
estadounidense más joven desde 1973 en
es week es con humildad que agradezco a
la gente de georgia por elegirme para
servirle mencionado de eeuu gracias por
la confianza que han depositado en mí
ya sea que estuvieran a mi favor en
contra estaré para ustedes en el senado
de eeuu serviré a toda la gente del
estado o soft quien ha revelado casos de
explotación sexual corrupción y crímenes
de guerra entre otros se une a otro
candidato histórico
raphael warnock quien se convierte en el
primer senador afroamericano del estado
el pastor evangélico de 51 años se
reconoce como heredero y discípulo de
martin luther king también agradeció a
sus seguidores
bajar para ponerme las botas y
representar las preocupaciones de la
gente en el senado de eeuu
warnock es conocido por su postura
progresista su defensa del aborto el
matrimonio homosexual y los derechos
civiles los resultados suponen una nueva
derrota para el presidente de trump en
sus últimos días en el cargo
los funcionarios republicanos del estado
culpan de las pérdidas a trump y a sus
señalamientos de fraude infundados por
favor que mientras los republicanos
atacaban al gobernador y a mi jefe
los demócratas tocaban puertas y hacían
que la gente votará las declaraciones
que el presidente sigue haciendo son
incorrectas y socavan la fe en el
proceso electoral en noviembre baiden se
convirtió en el primer candidato
presidencial demócrata en ganar en este
estado tradicionalmente rojo en casi
tres décadas
y esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france 24 continúen con
nosotros muy buen día para todos
[Música]